لا اصدق اننا يمكن ان نفعل ذلك لاشخاص
اخرين
ليسوا
هم عقبات
لذا فان الاستراتيجيه الاكبر امانا تتمثل
في القضاء عليهم
هذه ليست مجرد عمليه قتل
بل هي عمليه تدمير جوهرها تجاهل اي شيء
عدا القوه والسيطره
[موسيقى]
عيونك لا تتنازل
المقاس الوحيد
[موسيقى]
للحفاظ على سلامتك
انا كنت اخدم بالشام الشرطه العسكريه
كمصور
قبل الثوره
تصوير كل الحوادث الجنائيه العسكريه
مثل الغرب الحريق
الانتحار والقتل
هلا بعض الشهر الثالث 2011 كل شي يتغير كل
يوم الصبح يعني رئيس القسم يجيء اتصال من
مشفى تشرين لا يبعت المصور
المخابرات وبعض الوحدات الجيش
كانوا جثث الضحايا للمعتقلين في شاحنات
كبيره
وببدايه الثوره كان في بين
عشره اليوم
بس مع مرور الوقت
يعني
وصلنا نصور اكثر من اربعين جسر اليوم
لان المشرحه كانت صغيره
قرروا كل الجثث
لكراج بمشفى ثاني
مشفى 601
كنا نشوف قصص للشيوخ
شباب
حتى اطفال
كل الجثث كان في عليها لزقه او ورقه
فيها رقمين
هو الرقم هو للمعتقل
والثاني رقم الفرق
الطبيب الشرعي كان يطلب من المصور انه
ياخذ ثلاثه او اربع صور لكل جثه
بعدها كان في عساكر مهمتهم انهن يغلفوا
الجثث في البلاستيك
كنت
[موسيقى]
محتار شو بدي اعمل كنت امام خيارين اما
البقاء مع هذا النظام الدموي
ويصير شريف بالقتل
او الانشقاق والمخاطره بحياتي وحياته
[موسيقى]
كنت مهندس احمد في سوريا
بعد شهر ونصف تقريبا او شهرين من انطلاق
الثوره
تواصل معي سيزر
مع برفوك كان صوته كتير مرتبط وقال لي
لازم اشوفك
بده ياخذ قرار انه يترك الوظيفه
انا بالعكس
الحيتان يبقى قيصر في هذا الموقع
اقترحت عليه خليك مستمر بعملك
وخلينا نسحب هاي البيانات بشكل يومي
[موسيقى]
فنريد لاخوتنا السوريين واهلنا ان يعرفوا
اين ذهب ابنائهم المعتقلون
منهم ومن لا يزال في السجن وكذا
[موسيقى]
ديميليا
علينا ان نبدا بالجانب السياسي وهناك
الكثير من الضغط من قبل السوريين لانهم
يريدون ان تحل القضيه الان لقد كانوا على
اتصال لسنوات مع مجموعه لتقصي الحقائق
تسعى الى اقامه روابط بين العائلات وصور
قيصر
لكن امر اتمام العمليه منوط بنا اذ لا
توجد طريقه اخرى لقد اصبحنا املهم الوحيد
[موسيقى]
بدانا تحقيق في مايو ايار عندما اتصل بنا
اشخاص من الجاليه السوريه في المنفذ كانوا
يحاولون يائسين العثور على طريقه لاطلاق
متابعات قضائيه على اثر ما كشفته صور قيصر
[موسيقى]
الموقع تبعنا معلومات مشان اخوك الشهيد
خلال الاطلاعك على صور سيزر المنشوره على
الموقع تبعنا
السلام عليكم معك علاء من الجمعيه السوريه
في تواصل الاجتماعي نشروا تلك الصور
لمعرفه ما اذا كان بامكانهم العثور على
معلومات حول اقارب الضحايا
عندما اغلقت جميع الابواب في المحكمه
الجنائيه فان السوريين في المنفى ومن اجل
تحقيق اي عداله تولدت لديهم فكره محاوله
العثور على اشخاص يحملون جنسيه مزدوجه او
لديهم اقارب او روابط مع اي بلد في اوروبا
ديانه واخيرا وجدوا ان قريبه احد الضحايا
هي مواطنه اسبانيه
ما منحنا امكانيه رفع دعوى لدى القضاء
الاسباني
هذا هو جواز السفر الذي يقدمه الاقارب
لجماعات المعارضه عندما بداوا في التعرف
عليهم اذا كل شيء
في البدايه اخفاء اسمها واسم شقيقها وهو
ما لم يمثل مشكله من حيث المبدا
[موسيقى]
عبدول عبد هو اخي تعرف عليه ابن اخي في
ارشيف قيصر عندما تذهب الى الموقع
الالكتروني هنا في اسبانيا تجد العديد من
الصور التي يصعب التعرف عليها جيدا
ولكن امكن للعائله التعرف عليها حتى دون
عيون او انف يمكنهم ذلك لكن نعم قلت له
انه اخي
[موسيقى]
لماذا قتلوه عليهم ان يجيبوا هؤلاء بشر
اذا تم الاعتقال في حمص ولدينا معلومات عن
نقله وقتله في دمشق في سجن 248 الشهير
هذه هي الصور المنقوله الى العائلات والتي
يمكننا من خلالها التعرف على المكتب 248
الذي يتبع اجهزه المخابرات العسكريه
هذا واضح تماما في المذكره الاخيره بالضبط
انها ندبه وهذا ما مكن من التعرف عليه بما
لا يدع مجالا للشك
لقد خطا لعمليه ازاله زائده الدوديه
تقول شقيقه زوجته ان لديها السجل الطبي
يجب ان ترسله الينا
اختفى في عام 2013
كنت اتصل باستمرار اردت التحدث اليه اين
عبد اين عبد زوجته لم تخبرني باي شيء لكن
في احد الايام قلت لها انني اريد التحدث
اليه على الرغم من ان الساعه كانت الثانيه
صباحا فبدات بالبكاء حينها اعترفت ان
اربعه اشهر قد مرت على اختفائه
ستتحدثين معها المدينه شايفتينا
من الضروري ان نسمع صوتها اوضح قليلا في
سياق القضيه التي نحن بصدد العمل عليها
وانا اعلم انها ليست طريقه المسلى لاننا
بعيدون والوضع ليس لطيفا لكننا بحاجه الى
سماع قصتها وروايتها للحقائق بافضل طريقه
ممكنه
وكل يوم صار يسافر
36 يوم لحتى ياخذوها الشامي
هي تقول ان هذا صوت الاذان هل يجب ان
تتوقف لاداء الصلاه لا هذا في الخارج انه
شيء اخر
واساليها ما اذا كان خالك عضو نشطا في اي
منظمه او طائفه او نقابه
لا لم تكن تربطه اي صله بالسياسه او
المنظمات
هل يعيشون في منطقه يسيطر عليها النظام
نعم
وعلينا ان نفكر فيها ايضا هل ترغب بمغادره
البلاد
اخشى انها مثل اي انسان اخر ترغب
بالمغادره لكنها محتاره لان لديها اطفالا
وبالنظر الى ان لديها وظيفه مستقره فانها
تخشى المغادره ولا يمكننا اجبار شخص على
مغادره البلاد
لكن ما اود قوله هو انهم سيصلون اليه اذا
لم تكن ترغب بالرحيل لهذا اعتقد ان من
الضروري لها ان تغادر والا فان الخطر لا
يقتصر على امنها بل يمتد الى القضيه ايضا
[موسيقى]
مرحبا سيدتي اود لفت انتباهكم الى قضيه
اخي وابنه اللذين اعتقلتهما سلطات السوريه
في الثالث من تشرين الثاني نوفمبر 2013
اعتقال اخي وابن اخي ياتي بعض الكشف عن
ملف قيصر الحزين ومع ذلك وبما ان اساليب
النظام لم تتغير فكل المخاوف تبقى قائمه
بشان وضعهم اخي وابنه يحملان الجنسيتين
الفرنسيه والسوريه بالولاده
يدرس علم النفس في السنه الثانيه بجامعه
دمشق اختطف في منتصف ليل الثالث من تشرين
الثاني نوفمبر 2013
قدموا انفسهم كاعضاء في المخابرات الجويه
وفتشوا المنزل باكمله واخذوا النقود
واجهزه الكمبيوتر والهواتف ثم غادروا مع
باتريك وحده
وفي مساء اليوم التالي في منتصف الليل
جاءوا الاعتقال مازن الاب قائلين لقد اسات
تربيه ابنك سنعلمك كيف ترببنا وفي تلك
اللحظه بعد مغادره منزل مازن قاموا بجولات
واعتقالات في الحي حيث اخذوا اشخاصا اخرين
وصلوا ليلا الى مركز تحقيقات المزه الشهيه
هم اسرى للشائعه والشكوك وياملون ان
كليهما لا يزالان على قيد الحياه
مرحبا استاذ معذره
اريد ان اعرف ماذا حدث لهما لقد اختفيا
وهذا ليس طبيعيا
لما لا يمكننا زيارتهما لما لا تستطيع
زوجته رؤيته ليس لدينا اخبار مؤكده عن
مكانهما ومصيرهما
اولا نريد ان نعرف ما اذا كان على قيد
الحياه واينهما
هل عذيب هل نج
اياه من ماهي التهم المواجهه اليهما الامر
بهذه البساطه
ربما سنتحدث عن الشكوى
من ما على انه
وهذا يفترض مسبقا حدوث الاختطاف من قبل
السلطات ثم اخفاء مصيرهما نحن فعليا ضمن
هذا التصنيف
هل ستحال هذه الشكوى الى سلطات السوريه
ورد فعلهم تجاهها
فكذلك من الصعب تاكد او توقع على افتراض
انهما ما زال على قيد الحياه انه سيتم
اطلاق سراحهما
لو ان تخيلت سيناريو الاسوا حيث يقتلونهما
مباشره بعد تقديم الشكوى فساشعر بالذنب
طوال حياته فهو في النهايه يا اخي
طبعا
هذا هو لقاءنا الثالث عليك بالتفكير في
الامر لا نريد ان نستعجلك في اتخاذ القرار
وفي الوقت نفسه من واجبنا تنبيهك
تحتفظ بالشكوى
ساقراها الليله
سنواصل النظر في الامر المهم هو ان لا
نتصرف بعشوائيه
[موسيقى]
اخي مازن كان مستشارا تعليميا ل 25 عاما
في المدرسه الفرنسيه تشارل دو بدمشق
[موسيقى]
قريبا جدا من والده وكانت بينهما رابطه
متينه لطالما شعرت بهذا
تمتلك عائلتي منزلا كبيرا في دمشق
عندما كنا نذهب في اجازه كنا نلتقي بمازن
في هذا المنزل
[موسيقى]
عام 2013 عند اختفائهما نبهت السلطات
الفرنسيه
تم اطلاع الجميع
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
لم يكون رهنتين في دوله قانون هزني ما
سمعت هذا شخص من الوزاره يخبرني ان سوريا
دوله قانون بالنسبه لي هو لم يفهم اي شيء
[موسيقى]
شكرا
في جميع انحاء سوريا توجد مراكز احتجاز
داخل اقبيه مكونه من زنازير يتكدس فيها
المعتقلون
نعلم انهما نقل الى سجن المزه
انه مركز احتجاز يقع في مطار دمشق العسكري
نشرنا اسمائهم عبر كل هذه القنوات ولنشاط
لعل معتقلا هاربا يقول نعم رايت باتريك او
رايت مازن في تاريخ كذا كان على قيد
الحياه في مركز الاعتقال هذا
[موسيقى]
مقر الشرطه العسكريه بالشام
موجود في منطقه
لما كنا نوصل على الشغل كنا نشوف كتير ناس
من ساعه والشيوخ
كانوا بدهم يعرفوا النظام
وكان كل يوم
[موسيقى]
على امل انه يسمعوا شيء كان الشرطه يطلعوا
يضربوهم بيقلعوهم
كنا نخاف من انه نقول اي شيء
لان مصيرنا راح يكون مثل اللي عم يموتوا
بالمعتقلات اللي هو الموت
كل يوم المساء
بس يرجع المصور من مهمه التصوير
يعرف في حدا مسؤول عن نقل الصور من
الكاميرا للكمبيوتر الخاص بالقسم
كان يفرز صور الضحايا لمجلدات
كل جسه حسب الفرع اللي اجت منه
[موسيقى]
من الفرع 248 قص ولصق لمجلد الفرع 248
وهيك
كان معاون رئيس القسم ومسؤول للكمبيوتر
يضلوا يشتغلوا لبعد الساعه 2:00 بالليل
[تصفيق]
القسم كان مكلف بكتابه تقرير مصور عن كل
المعتقلين
ويبعتوا كل يوم الصبح على القضاء العسكري
[تصفيق]
انا صورت تقرير بشكل سري لحتى يكون معي
تمام طبيب الشرعي
كان لازم يذكر سبب الوفاه لكل الجثه
وغالبا كان يقول
سبب توقف القلب والتنفس
كنت
انسخ الصور بشكل سري تماما
كل يوم بعد نص الليل طبعا
بس اتاكد انه ما في حدا بالمكتب
كان القلق والخوف مرافقين من كل الوقت بس
اطلعوا من الشغل من الشرطه العسكريه وامرق
على الحواجز حتى وصل على
لما بنشوف الصور في في ملف الضحايا
ربما نستغرب كيف يقوم النظام بتوثيق
جرائمه دون
ان يعمل اي حساب
لاي جهه اخرى يتم اكتشافها في صور غيرهم
بعض التبريرات كانت ان كل فرحه من هو مضطر
ان يثبت ان المعتقل الفلاني قد مات
كتير كان مهم بسوريا
عنده ضباط الامن اثبات الولاء
بعض الضباط ممكن يهرب معتقل بمقابل مادي
لحتى يتم نفي هذه التهمه تماما ولعقوب
تدبير كتير عم النظام
كان لابد من الاسراء على عمليه التوثيق
الكامل
جميع الصور التي
اخرجناها فيما يسمى بملف قيصر
هم اشخاص تم قتلهم في هذه الاماكن التابعه
لنظام السوري
الوحده وخمسه عشر فرع 216 220 27 35 48 51
المخابرات الجويه في سوريا هذه تعني افروع
امنيه فرع افرع المخابرات
يشعر الناظر ان هذا هو توقيع القاتل على
جسد الضحيه
بان يكتب هذا الرقم وكانه ختم على جسد
الضحيه بتوقيعه
بشكل يعني
محزن جدا ومؤلم
لا نعرف بصراحه لماذا انتهى المطاف بعبد
الى الفرع 248
اذا عثرت على شاهد عيان يقول رايتهم
يطلقون عليه النار بعد تعرضه للتعذيب ثم
يتركونه في مكان محدد فلا شك انه سيكون
مفيدا لنا
[موسيقى]
عندما تحاول اثبات جريمه ضد الانسانيه
فانك تبني روايه قائمه على العنف
واستخدامه ضد اشخاص متعددين عنف متكرر
ينطوي على عناصر مشتركه
انهم ناجون من السجن لذلك يمكننا تكوين
صوره واضحه تبين كيف لوحق هؤلاء وان
اعتقلوا وكيف نقلوا وكيف وصلوا
[موسيقى]
كنت لابس قميص
وصلنا كبو علي مي لحونه بس ضلينا بالسليب
هل كان يعرف الى اين سينقل
لسه ما نعرف احنا وين فتحوا باب غرفه
وكبسونا دفره وفوتوني
وقعت بالارض
[موسيقى]
الزاويه واحد اثنين ثلاثه اربعه خمسه سته
سبعه ثمانيه تسعه عشره تمام يقول قعده
تمام
هل كانت هناك اعمار مختلفه اطفال ومراهقون
من العشر سنين
الم يجمعوا ابدا بين الرجال والنساء
الثاني
فينا نسمع صوت تعذيبهم
بعدين
اول اسبوع تقريبا طلبوني على التحقيق
طبعا
شو اسمك
مظاهرات كذا كنت اصور لك اصوره
الجيش العربي السوري على على عبوات ناس
تمام
قلت له اول شغله انا لا شفته سلاح وبكره
السلاح ما اعترفت جابوني حطوني
هيك
كلفشه طبعا هو شباك تماما بكلبشه من هون
كلفشه من هون ويرفعوني عن الارض 40 سم
تماما تحس الكلبشات تريد تقطع ايدينك
يجيب حذاء يحطه يقول لك
تمام نزلني قلت له
ساعتين الصبح وساعتين المساء
هل توقف التعذيب والمعامله السيئه
تمام يعني
من المسؤول من يعطي الاوامر
ما يقف في الخلفيه للتاكد من ان التعذيب
مستمر من الصباح الى المساء وحتى قتل
الشخص ثم تصويره
نحن لا نتحدث فقط عن عبد وعن مقتله كحادثه
فرديه
الخطه الامنيه طبقت في سوريا منذ مارس
اذار 2011 في سياق احداث الربيع العربي
في 2011 اثراء اثر المظاهرات في ذلك العام
وجراء التدخل قوات الامن توفي السيد
[موسيقى]
هذا هو عبد نعرف انه كان سائق توصيل بين
حمص وحماه والقي القبض عليه في وقت ما من
عام 2013 وكان هذا تاريخ اختفائه على ما
نظن
كثيرا ما يلقى القبض على الاشخاص عند نقاط
التفتيش لان فيها قوائم بالاشخاص
المطلوبين لكن دون صور مجرد قوائم لذا في
نقطه التفتيش يتوقف رجل ربما كان اسمه
يتطابق مع شخص مطلوب لن اقول لاسباب
مشروعه ولكن من كان مطلوبا دعنا نقول من
كان معارضا حقيقيا للنظام
حسنا لكن دعونا نتاكد من اننا نفهم بعضنا
البعض ماذا يعني الاشراف على نقطه تفتيش
هل تشغلها هل تديرها كيف تشرف على نقطه
تفتيش
كانت ترتيب برمته يستهدف نقل اعداد هائله
من الناس وفقا للتوجيهات الصادره عن
الخليه المركزيه لاداره الازمات
هذه استراتيجيات منسقه للاعتقالات
والاخفاء الجماعي والتعذيب والاعدام
وضعت الخليه المركزيه لاداره الازمات
تصنيفات للاشخاص الذين سيتم اعتقادهم
اولئك الذين يشاركون في المظاهرات واولئك
الذين يمولون المظاهرات واولئك الذين
يتحدثون الى الصحفيين الاجانب ويلطخون اسم
سوريا في المجال الدولي وهلم جرا لكن
النظام لم يكن دقيقا وكان وحشيا لدرجه انه
بمجرد القبض عليك فانك تصبح مذنبا في نظر
النظام
هذا شيء لا نجده الا في النظام ستاليني
الخليه المركزيه لاداره الازمات تضع
السياسه وهؤلاء هم الاعضاء الرئيسيون في
الخليه المركزيه لاداره الازمات وكل هؤلاء
القاده الكبار في الدوله السوريه خدموا في
تلك اللجنه
كانت الاجتماعات تعقد يوميا تقريبا
ثم يتم اعداد محضر من ذلك الاجتماع ويتم
نقله الى القصر الرئاسي للموافقه عليه او
تصحيحه او تعديله من قبل الاسد نفسه
مع ذلك الرئيس بشار الاسد
لين في
الخليج كان فقط يدقق ملاحظات كل اجتماع
ويصادق على التعليمات
علينا ان ناخذ بعين الاعتبار اننا سنقدم
هذا الى قاض اسباني ليست لديه فكره عن سير
هذه الامور ويجب ان نتمكن من تحديدها
هؤلاء الافراد فكيف سنفعل ذلك
لدينا الكثير من الوثائق التي تبين كيف
يتداخل الدور فرع 248 مع منظومه القمع هذه
لذا من وجهه نظر قانونيه الامر واضح من
حيث تحديد مسؤوليه القياده عما تخبرني به
وهو القتل غير القانوني للسيد عبد
[موسيقى]
نعم نعم من المهم التعرف عليهم كي نتمكن
من تحديد مستوى سلطتهم
سيعود مازن الى منزله يوما ما امل ذلك لكن
لن يكون لديه شيء
[موسيقى]
تستغل الناس الوضع ولم يكن هناك احد
فجاءوا وسكنوا البيت ها هم يجلسون على
الشرفه وهناك اطفال يلعبون الان
عرفنا ان شخصا من المخابرات الجويه هو
الذي استقر في هذا المنزل
وعرفنا من الاسم انه هو الذي يتعامل مع
ملك مازن ففهمنا على الفور انه كان عملا
شريرا من خلال اخذ مازن ووضعه في السجن
يمكنهم في النهايه مصادره المنزل انه عمل
مافيا بامتياز ومن قبل اناس في غايه
الوداع
لابد ان نصل الى الحقيقه يجب ان يدركوا
انه في يوم ما سيتم تحقيق العداله
الذي يحدد الوتيره هو عبيده
الان تم اتخاذ القرار سنقدم هذه الشكوى
يوم الاثنين
يجب ان نمضي قدما
اذا اصدر النظام السوري غدا كرد بيانا
رسمي يقول فيه انه بسبب هذه الشكوى تم
اعدامهما في صباح اليوم التالي فساشعر
بانني المسؤوله
وفي الوقت نفسه اذا كان لا يزالان على قيد
الحياه فهذه طريقه لحمايتهما كاننا نقول
احذر سيرتفع سعرهما
باتريك ومازن الدباغ سيدخلان في قائمه
المعتقلين المختفين الذين فتح تحقيق من
اجلهم وقد تكون هناك مبادرات من اجلهما
ايضا لانهما مواطنان فرنسي
[موسيقى]
تسليط الضوء على مازن ربما يكون سببا في
تحريرهما
هل تريدين السكر دانا نعم من فضلك يا امي
نعم من فضلك
اعملوا ان تؤتي الجهود التي تبذلها ثمارها
امر ذلك ايضا انه محظوظ لوجودك
[موسيقى]
تعرف هذا
ربما بلى ابي
كل هذا ليس عبثا
سنفوز بالتاكيد
التحقيق يبدا الان المدعي العام فتح
تحقيقا قضائيا في حالات الاختفاء القصري
والتعذيب والجرائم ضد الانسانيه
المثير في هذه القضيه اننا نعلم انه
موسيقى الى فرع تحقيق المزه
ونعلم ايضا انهما اعتقل من قبل المخابرات
الجويه
بمجرد احتجاز الافراد واستجوابهم غالبا ما
يجبرون من خلال العنف الجسدي في كثير من
الحالات على الادلاء باسماء افراد الاخرين
فينتهي المطاف باسماء هؤلاء على قوائم
المطلوبين
لذا يمكن ان يكون هذا هو السيناريو الذي
ادى الى احتجاز كل من الاب والابن
الوثائق ستكون المفتاح
لدينا الان اكثر من 600 الف صفحه من وثائق
النظام التي يمكن ان تدعمكم
وهي ذات صله بقضيتكم
[موسيقى]
معظم هذه الوثائق صدرت عن جهاز المخابرات
الامنيه
[موسيقى]
والاستخباراتيه
طلبت منهم البحث عن سمي باتريك ومازن في
قاعده بياناتهم
[موسيقى]
فربما ظهر في تقرير استجواب او في تقرير
اعتقاد
[موسيقى]
لكن دون جدوى
لكن من ناحيه اخرى لدينا الكثير من
الوثائق من اجهزه المخابرات الجويه التي
يمكن ان تظهر اسماء المسؤولين في وقت
اختطاف واعتقال واختفاء باتريك
[موسيقى]
عبد بخصوص مغادره البلاد
وما اذا كانوا على علم بقضيه جنائيه ضد
اعضاء في الدوله ومن قوات الامن على وجه
الخصوص اذ نخشى ان يكون هناك رد فعل
انتقامي
[تصفيق]
ترسل كل شيء بمجرد ان نعطي الضوء الاخضر
لبي بي بي سي ام ان والجزيره او جزيره
وصحيفه التانس في لندن مهتمه لكنهم
ينتظرون ايضا
يهمني ان تغادر السيده البلاد قبل ان نبدا
وليحدث بعدها ما يحدث اذ ستكون بامان مع
اطفالها
عندما تحدثنا الى الزوجه مساء امس في
حوالي 12 ليلا والواحده بعد منتصف الليل
لتوقيتها اشارت الى انها ستستقل الحافله
عند الفجر ولم ترغب في ركوب سياره اجره او
سياره خاصه لان ذلك قد يلفت الانتباه اليه
وعده انها ستكون في مناطق الثوار بحلول
الثانيه بعد الظهر وهذا اامن فقد شهدنا
الكثير من القصص الماس اويه
حسنا شكرا ويسعدني ان يكون الجميع في
الوقت نفسه هنا في مدريد ولا سيما سامي
واملوا ان تنقلوا ترحيبنا بقيصر بطريقه ما
حدث
واود ان اعرض على سامي شكوى اذا ما رغب
بذلك
ايضا
تمت تسميتهم
الصفحات الثالثه والرابعه تحتوي يعني على
الاسنان
الاوراق المطبوعه على الوجهين محمد
ايمكن ان اقول الاسماء محمد الحاج علي عبد
الفتاح قدسيه
جميل الحسن وهذا الوقت يحتجز عمي
يحتجز عمي مملوك
[موسيقى]
بعدين محمد
ما هي مشكله ايه يعني بتقدروا تاخذوا بدكم
اياه
يعني ان شاء الله
مع السلامه
قلقه للغايه لان الرحله خطره هي خائفه بعد
الشيء بسبب الحرب ونقاط التفتيش وما الى
ذلك
انا متاثره جدا ومرتبكه
امل وان يسير كل شيء على ما يرام
الجميع يريد ان يكون محامي حقوق انسان حتى
انا وما زلت احاول
اصعب شيء ان تكون قادرا على فعل ما تقول
للضحايا انك ستفعله
صدام والا لا ترفع سقفه توقعات لا يمكنك
تحقيقها
عندنا
[موسيقى]
اردنا ان نقابلكم لابلاغكم وجها لوجه
بالعناصر الاخيره التي تم ادخالها في
الملف
ساريكم مقتطفات واوامر هذه اوامر باسمه
وتوقيعه لديكم مثال هنا
لدينا وثائق مؤرخه في السادس من فبراير
عام 2011 من فبراير عام 2012 والسابع
والعشرين من فبراير عام 2014
موقعه من جميل حسن اوامر مباشره للغايه
محاله الى فرع التحقيقات تحديدا الذي سيق
اليه باتريك ومازن وتتحدث عن احتجاز او
اعتقال افراد معينه حسنا
لانه ليس مسؤولا بالتسلسل الوظيفي فقط بل
هو مشارك فيما يحدث
وهناك حقيقه اخرى مثيره للاهتمام وهي ان
الوثائق تؤكد اسم الشخص الذي كان رئيسا
على الاقل حتى يونيو 2012 ولكن علينا
تقديم الادله الاض لغايه نوفمبر 2013
بخصوص من كان يراس هذا الفرع من التحقيقات
وهو عبد السلام محمود هذا كل شيء انه
جميل حسن وعبد السلام محمود اسباني سمعني
عنهما كثيرا
طبعا لكن هناك فارق بين تكرار سماع
الاسماء وبين وجود وثائق وادله وشهد هذا
يقوي القضيه
لمعرفه مصيرهم هل مازالوا مسجونين هل
كانوا ربما في سجن اخر
القبيل
كلا ليس لدينا اي مؤشر على ذلك سوى تقرير
قيصر الذي يشير الى احتمال وجود مثل هذه
السجلات سجلات لمن ياتي ومن يغادر ومن
ينقلب
لكن بعد كل هذه الخطوات اجد من المذهل بعد
ثلاث سنوات ونصف الا نعرف حتى ما اذا كان
على قيد الحياه او اينهما ابي قام بالكثير
من الاجراءات وفي كل مره كنت اعتقد اننا
سنحصل على اجابات ومازلنا لا نعرف شيئا
اعرف اعرف نحن نتقدم لكن بخطوات صغيره جدا
[موسيقى]
شكرا لكم على الجهد المبذول لكن كلما
غادرنا نقول لانفسنا يا الهي مازلنا لا
نملك ايه اخبار
نعم اعرف
اعرف اود ان اخبركم
في الحقيقه تابني ولبضعه اشهر شعور سيء
حيال ذلك
من الصعب جدا ان لا تعرف
سنكتشف يوما ما سترين لا يوجد سبب لالا
نعرف
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
السلطات الفرنسيه يصم الاذى
وهو صمت لا يمكن تفسيره
[موسيقى]
عن تدخل محتمل من قبل الدوله الفرنسيه
لصالح باتريك
[موسيقى]
الاجابه الوحيده التي حصل عليها هي دعوته
للتوقف عن السؤال
[موسيقى]
يبدو ان مدعين عامين يتبعون امرا سياسيا
مباشرا وبغض النظر عن اي اعتبار يعارضون
هذا النوع من القضايا
قضيه الضحايا السوريين شيء لا تملك
اسبانيا الجراه للنهوض به
هذه الضحيه ليس لديها مكان اخر في العالم
لتذهب اليه فهي مواطنه اسبانيه وليس
امامها اليه دوليه كالجو اليها لذا فان
حرمانها من هذه الفرصه لمتابعه القضيه في
اسبانيا تركها بلا قوه انها اسبانيه انها
ضحيه جريمه ولا يمكنها الذهاب الى اي مكان
في العالم
[موسيقى]
هذا كل ما حصلنا عليه
باستمرار ان يتوقف موكلي عن الوثوق به
وجهه سيكون الوجه الذي يرونه حين يتذكرون
اسوا ما حدث لهم في حياتهم
هذا شيء يؤرقني في كل مره نتلقى فيها
اخبارا سيئه
وجود
باستمرار في
بحوزه اثناء التنقل والسفر
في من النسخه ايضا بحوز القيصر
فاللعب ليس فقط مادي انني احمل هذا
معي اينما كان لكن هو ايضا عبء نفسه
صوره تتذكر
الكثير من الوجوه شوفهم بنوم احيانا
ادول الاشخاص اللي انا استطعت ان وثق
حالات استشهاد
انا مسؤول
فبشعر انه وجود قريبين مني باستمرار
بيعطيني
شعور انه
مهمتك لسه ما خلصت
لم نترك طريقا او سبيلا الا وقصدناه
الذين تم اعتقالهم وتعذيبهم
ولكن
ني اليوم اشعر انني خزنت القيصر
الامم المتحده اغلقت ابواب
افتحوا انتم ابواب العداله في
هذه البلدان العريقه
[موسيقى]
كانت هناك الكثير من الجثث في مكان ضيق
استخدموا هذا المراب القريب من القصر
الرئاسي
فوق هيك هو خايف
خايف حدا ياخد له صوره او حدا يعرفه
[موسيقى]
ان يموت لكن نحن اللي لازم نحافظ على حياه
وقوه هذا الملف
فالملف الذي نحمله كاماني سيكون العقبه
الاكبر في وجه اعاده تلميع او تسويق رموز
النظام في سوريا
[موسيقى]
الملك للشعب السوري
ليست ملك لي او ملك
[موسيقى]
وانما هي ملك لكل شخص يسعى الى تحقيق
العداله في العالم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
زيتون
[موسيقى]
وح
ماده
ناظم محمد
[موسيقى]
يحيى الشورب
جي
[موسيقى]
عبد العزيز الخيال
لازم
دبابريك عبد القاد
ر
[موسيقى]
سوريا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في شهر تموز من هذا العام وصلتنا اخبار
شفهيه من احد عناصر الامن ان مازن وتقريج
توفي تحت التعذيب
طلبنا حينها عن طريق العائله بدمشقنا
فرديه لكل منهما وحصلنا عليها
شهادات الوفاه هذه هي الدليل الدامغ
هم الذين وقعوا عليها هم يعترفون لنا
بانهم اعتقلوا
وقتلوهما هذا ما تعنيه شهادات الوفاه هذه
ولدينا تواريخ محدده للغايه في يناير 2014
اي بعد اعتقاله بشهرين
نوفمبر 2017 لمازن
ظل مازن على قيد الحياه
رهن الاحتجاز اي لا نعرف حتى نوفمبر 2017
هذا يثير الكثير من الاسئله الكثير حول
معنى كل هذا وحول معنى كل هذه المعركه
لاننا نعم لم نتمكن من اخراجه من هناك
عندما كان لا يزال على قيد الحياه في ذلك
الوقت
[موسيقى]
سليمان
السلام عليكم وعليكم السلام ورحمه الله
اهلين استاذ ابراهيم
والتسبب بوفاه او المسؤوله عن وفاه ما
يقارب خمسين ضحيه
لحد الان تم استماع لعده شهود وعده ضحايا
اول مره تم عرض الصور
قيصر بالمحكمه تمت
فعلا بتمنى اشوف رده فعل اثناء عرض
الصور الملف لكن للاسف الاجراءات الامنيه
ليست كافيه وتدعوا لاخذ الحيطه والحذر
شكرا السلام
[موسيقى]
للمحكمه الاتحاديه وبناء عليه المدعي
العام لجمهوريه المانيا الاتحاديه لقد كنا
اول من اطلق هذا الفحص الطبي واول من طبق
مثل هذه الخبره الطبيه الجنائيه الكامله
على ما تضمنته الملفات
مكننا من تقديم لائحه اتهام اوليه ضد
اثنين من موظف المخابرات السوريه لجا الى
هنا الى المانيا
وهنا برزت اهميه ملفات قيصر بالنسبه لنا
حيث يمكننا استخدامها كاساس للاجراءات ضد
الافراد
هؤلاء الاشخاص قد ماتوا الا اننا نريد ان
يستمر في العيش من خلال هذه التقارير
الطبيه القانونيه التي توضح ما حدث لهم
هناك اردنا ان نجعلها قابله للاستخدام في
محاكماتنا الجنائيه وللمحاكمات الجنائيه
لشركائنا في اوروبا وربما لاستخدامها
كاساس لمحاكمه جنائيه دوليه
تعرفت بصور قيصر على صوره زوجي وصوره اخي
انا تعرفت بصور قيصر
تعرفت على صوره ابني ايهم وهو شهيد
فالصور اللي شفتها في اطفاء للحياه مش
بس قد زوجي احمد لما اعتقل كان عمره 46
سنه
انا انتزعت روحي
مع زوجي اتعذب هذا التعذيب ومات
انا اذا بعرف مين قتل اخوي بقتله
لانه اللي قتل اخوي ما قتل اخوي لحاله
قتلنا كلياتنا
ليش اخذتني عن الفرع على على الاقبية
تبعكم
وعذبتني ودبكت على صدري وقلعت عيني وكسرت
اسناني ليش صار رقم على جبهتي
لا ما منعرف وين جثه ابي ابدا او وين ما
تكون ما بنعرف شيء
ما دام قبر حمزه غير موجود الحزن سيبقى
يشتعل ويزيد يعني لا يمكن ان يطفئه شيء
صح هو ميت بس انه في قبر يعني ممكن انت
تحسي انه هو قريب منك يعني يعود الواحد
يحكي معه
قل صباح نسمع الاخبار
لنعرف اللي عم بيصير بسوريا
ولحد اليوم في كتير معتقلين
يعذبون ويقتلون
بنفس المكان وبنفس الطريقه
انا ولا لحظه من وقت طلعت من سوريا حسيت
بالندم كان واجبي يخبر العالم
[موسيقى]